[Applause]
a show of force on the streets of sri
lanka's capital colombo
[Music]
public discontent has been simmering for
months over an economy close to
bankruptcy
[Music]
prime minister mahinda rajapaksa has
bowed down to pressure to resign
today's resignation is long overdue
but is unlikely to address the cause the
demands of the protesters so even
despite the curfew and a state of
emergency many are on the roads now
because they feel their calls their
demands need to be heard
demonstrators have rallied for weeks
outside the offices of rajapaksa and his
brother president gotta pay rajapaksa
demanding both step down
on monday morning a pro-government group
stormed a protest camp outside the prime
minister's office
attacking people with sticks and metal
bars and destroying the tents
cues for food fuel and medicine are
common for the 22 million sri lankans
the pandemic loss of tourism and rising
oil prices are all hitting hard
foreign reserves have dwindled to about
50 million dollars the monthly gas
import bill is 40 million dollars
the government has turned to the
international monetary fund for a
bailout
but that would take at least six months
to be finalized
a state of emergency and curfew have
been imposed and the military deployed
on the streets
but public anger remains and so do
demands for the president to follow his
brother and resign to
law about manly al jazeera
well let's speak to ahilan kadir gamar
about this he's a political economist
and joins us from jaffna in northern sri
lanka thank you so much for being with
us and for your patience so
after growing pressure the prime
minister has resigned do you think this
will be enough to appease protesters
no the demand of the protesters has been
that the
entire family who has governed this
country over the last three years should
resign and and crucial here is the
president the brother of the prime
minister who holds tremendous power uh
in fact soon after he came to power he
passed an amendment to the constitution
to keep even more power so until the
president goes i think these protests
are going to continue
but even if the president resigns i mean
even if the president resigns and and
the rajapaksa family is out of the
picture
that's not going to to address the main
issue here which is the economic crisis
sri lanka is facing today it's worse
since its independence
yeah this is going to be a very long
drawn out crisis but we need to
immediately start working towards
solutions
and
the president having lost all legitimacy
he just can't lead this country out of
this crisis in fact
the longer he stays in power we are
approaching a state of anarchy even
today when the prime minister resigned
his goons went and attacked
peaceful protesters and now
there is violence all over the country
and a
state of curfew has been
imposed so this kind of situation is
going to continue almost in a sort of
anarchic manner until the president
resigns and then of course they're going
to have to uh pick up the pieces and
really start working towards rebuilding
our economy and that might take five to
ten years even so we're going to see a
lot of political changes right over the
next
years in tandem with this economic
crisis right as laura mentioned in her
report before we came to you the
government has of course officially
requested emergency uh financial help
from the international monetary fund
which some people have said has come too
late now how might the political crisis
that is unfolding now affect the
negotiations with the imf
i think not just the imf sri lanka is
also trying to get support from india
and china and other countries just to
even get some
bridge financing to get over the next
six months but when there is so much uh
political instability uh it provides
very little confidence to even uh get
that kind of financing and on the other
hand uh you know with the strikes
tomorrow uh it's likely to be a national
day of protest and strikes that are
going to continue indefinitely right and
then the economy also gets affected
there so we have to get production going
our services back and while this
political crisis lasts it's just going
to make the economic hardship that much
more harsher tell us a bit more about
the economic hardship that sri lankans
are facing today because i mean public
conversations
on the crisis include of course a wide
range of issues from you know
agricultural policies and trade
regulation monetary foreign policy as
well and foreign credit sorry how does
that translate into everyday life for
the average sri lankan what what has a
crisis meant for people
so petrol and diesel are in short supply
the prices of those um fuel have also
doubled in the last couple months but in
in addition to that people have to wait
in hours to get
fuel cooking gas is in short supply in
fact a couple days ago
a lorry carrying cooking gas cylinders
was looted so um and then the price of
rice has doubled
uh bread is in short supply the price of
bread has doubled so both price hikes
and
shortages has really enraged uh the
people and and a lot of the anger that
we are seeing against
uh the prime minister and the and the
president is about the complete
mismanagement of the economy
thank you so much for talking to us
about this thank you for your time
ahilan
gama political economist and senior
lecturer at the university of jaffna in
sri lanka